If you were suddenly teleported
into a world
where dead spirits walked the earth,
what would you do?
These terrifying
ghosts are trying to kill you,
and there's no way out of this nightmare.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do,
and how to beat the terrifying ghosts
in corpse party.
These kids have no idea.
They are all about to die.
Horrible deaths.
One day after school,
they sit around a dark classroom
as this girl,
Ayumi tells a horrifying story
that happened in this school
many years ago.
This place was run
by a headmaster who treated this school
like it was his own child.
But after one teacher died
falling down the stairs,
along with a bunch of other murders
taking place.
The headmaster was forced
to shut down the school forever.
And he went so insane from it
that he threw himself off of the roof
of his own school.
She also mentions that their school,
Cassadaga Academy, was built
on top of the very ruins of the school
where all the murders took place,
and that the place below them was called
Heavenly Host Elementary School.
Ayumi then says that the teacher who died
falling down the stairs, that her spirit
sometimes wanders these very hallways
on rainy days just like this.
And this kid named Satoshi
freaks the hell out at this horror story
and wants to go home.
But the others beg Ayumi
to finish her horrifying story.
The rest of these kids have a death wish.
They just don't know it yet.
Then they hear two sinister knocks
coming from the classroom door,
just like in Ayumi story
and the candle suddenly goes out, the door
slightly opens, and the class
holds their breath in terror.
But it turns out
he was just their friendly teacher.
And this one kid gets way too excited
at the sight of the teacher.
The teacher then tells them to head home,
but they decide to play one
last friendship game
since one of them is leaving school.
This girl,
they decided to play one last game
to make sure they stay friends forever.
A game that is about to change their lives
in the most terrifying way possible.
The students
then gather and hold this paper charm
cutout, and then they all collectively
pull it apart at the same time.
Now, as long as they each
keep their piece of paper,
their friendship will last forever.
And that was their biggest mistake.
Suddenly, the ground violently shakes,
causing the school to shutter,
and Ayumidst the shaking, the whole group
is plunged down into total darkness.
And that's when this girl, Naomi, suddenly
wakes up in a creepy looking classroom
all alone.
Shortly after that, though,
she also finds this girl with her hair
looking like she got two meatballs
hanging from each side of her head.
We'll call her meatball
hair girl and meatball hair girl
says that maybe they're
in some kind of spirit world,
and they then both try to figure out
just what in the hell is going on.
Okay, shit. Just got real.
And we literally have no clue
as to how we just got here,
what's going on, or where we are, though.
Isn't it weirld;y suspicious
that meatball hair girl
just guessed off the top of her head
that they're in the spirit world?
It's kind of suspicious
and random as hell.
Why didn't you think? Oh,
we'll let that slide for now.
First thing's
first mindset is half the battle.
So it's important that we don't panic
and take things slow,
because any such panicking and worrying
about stuff is now going to help us
control our emotions or the major
stress hormones flooding our body.
Because if we let them take over,
it will weaken
the connections in our brain and limit
the function of our prefrontal cortex,
which is the part of the brain
that does all of the rational information
processing.
By the way, being calm will tell us
that if we remember the earthquake made
everyone in the room
go down with us, including our teacher.
So where are our friends?
The first thing that I would do
would be to look around
for our friends and our teacher.
Are they okay? Is everyone hurt?
These are the things that I would check
first.
I would also make sure
that I'm not hurt myself
now if I can't find my friends
or my teacher, which does not make sense
because they fell down here
into the same spot where we are.
So we should be able to find them
or the remains of them.
But assuming we can't find them,
we can't wait around here forever
though we should wait around
for just a few minutes.
We did just fall through a freaking floor
that would cause some loud noise,
which would make it
very likely that someone nearby
or something would come and find us.
Now, if nothing happens after
waiting a few minutes,
we should get up and look around.
We should also look and see
if our own cell phone works.
But if our cell phone doesn't work,
we should pay attention to the fact
that this place looks like a school
just like ours,
which means that this place is bound
to have a phone somewhere.
And we need to find it.
Because, remember, we don't have
our friends, we don't have our teacher.
We're all alone,
and we need as much information
as we can in order to get out of here.
The two girls
try to figure out where they are as Naomi
hears a creepy laugh in the distance.
But meatball hair girl hears nothing.
The two.
Then check out the rest of the
scary place, just as this creepy ass girl
stalks them from behind meatball hair.
Girl then hits the bathroom
before they both head down the stairs.
And on the way down there, she gets
a little too happy to be alone with Naomi.
Just then they see the front door
and their take it out of there.
They also notice a bunch of little kids
shoes lying everywhere.
They then wonder
if they are in an elementary school
and the front door seems to be locked
just there.
Now we here's another horrifying laugh
at the distance as meatball hair grows,
says that they should spend the night here
until they figure things out.
The tooth then head to the nurse's office
to find some beds and meatball.
Her girl helps bandage up Ayumi's foot.
That appears to have been hurt
during the fall, the tooth and cuddle
up suspiciously close
and prepare to go to bed.
But that's when meatball haired girl here
suddenly realizes that she lost her
piece of paper.
This paper chant
that they all took from earlier thinking
she left it in the bathroom.
She heads over there, leaving
Naomi all alone to rest.
All of a sudden, the lights in the room
go out and Naomi finds herself paralyzed
and can't move a muscle.
Suddenly this book begins
scribbling shit all by itself
and the walls begin to bleed.
Blood unable to move,
she is forced to lay there and watch
as the room turns into a nightmare.
The air then begins to change and form
into a terrifying spirit as it terrorizes
Naomi to the point of insanity.
Just when she couldn't bear it
any longer, she suddenly hears the screams
of Meatball, her girl, and the distance
this shocks her and allows her to break
free from the paralyzing spell and escape.
The spirit chases after her,
but suddenly disappears.
She suddenly sees a corpse
to fall off its chair and even sees
this little girl who smiles with blood
dripping out of her mouth.
Naomi screams and runs,
but just then Meatball her girl
returns, suddenly, making all of this
scariness surrounding them.
Stop.
Naomi is pissed as hell
and made by her girl
and yells at her for leaving her behind,
causing Meatball her girl to storm off.
A couple of moments later, Naomi then
feeling bad for being a big, fat meanie.
She then hears Meatball her girl
in the bathroom and goes in to find her.
But something's not right now.
Ayumi then suddenly hears a noise coming
from one of the bathroom stalls slowly
opening the door, she finds a nightmare
that she never would have dreamt of
in her most terrifying dreams.
Meatball her girl.
But somehow still alive, Naomi tries
to save her rushing to find something
to prop up meatball hair girl's feet with
finding this bucket full of nastiness.
But that's when the scream stops
and only comes back to find strands of
meatball hair draping down from a dead
meatball hair girl.
Okay, this is insane.
And more importantly,
Naomi was too busy thinking about what
a horrible friend she was to help out
poor meatball hair girl.
She could have easily saved her,
at least for a little while longer,
if she acted faster
and now just mope around like an idiot.
But her kicking the bucket
could have happened in one of three ways.
The first is based on the actual rope
coming into contact with the area
around the neck,
where the rope physically constricts
the carotid arteries and basically stops
a blood flow from reaching the brain.
The second method is by cervical fracture
or by breaking your neck from a drop.
But the way meatball hair
girl was squirming
means that she likely died the second way.
Gasping for breath
and her last moments of life.
Truly a horrific way to have it all end.
But what makes me more annoyed
was how useless Naomi was
because she shouldn't
have even left her side to begin with.
Much like a kid
being put on the shoulders of a parent.
Naomi should have done this exact thing
as this would have provided.
Meanwhile, her girl
with a much more stable platform
from which
she could have caught her breath
while Naomi figured out an actual plan
to get her down from there.
Now, realistically, Naomi would have to go
look for something to cut her down with.
And by the looks of things where the rope
is wrapped up around that wooden beams
structure, there seems to be enough
clearance up there to fit a person.
So firstly, I would put Meatball her girl
on my shoulders for a second.
Let her catch your breath,
and then I would tell her
if she could climb up
onto that wooden beam with a noose
still attached to her neck, and from there
she could rest and this would free up.
Now, me to go look for something sharp
to cut her down with
just then this glasses
girl pops up to a broken heart of Naomi
and she tells her
that meatball hair girl came into contact
with the curse of this place
and that she tried to protect her mind
before the curse could kill her
glasses girl then tells her
what's really going on around here.
She mentions that a bunch of other kids
from other schools
have been sent here to die,
just like Naomi's Class.
Because the curse of this school drives
angry spirits to kill everyone inside
and it will turn everyone in here
dead or alive, batshit crazy,
making everybody eventually kill everybody
dead space style and their souls
will eventually be absorbed
by this school.
Elsewhere, Satoshi
and his little sister, Sweet Mochida, read
an old newspaper that they find
which reports on the horrifying incident
that took place here in 1973.
The newspaper
reports that after a month of children
disappearing of the case being closed,
the police discovered the corpses
of all the missing children,
along with this crazy school teacher.
Behind all of this, Satoshi then realizes
that this must be the horrifying story
that Ayumi
was telling them at the beginning,
and he wonders how they can be inside.
Heavenly Host Elementary School
since it was torn down ages ago.
But this kid doesn't have time to think
because his sister has to pee.
So the two set off to find her a bathroom
and to look for the others.
They then run into glasses.
Guy here taking pictures of somebodies
bloody guts on the wall
like a creep glasses guy.
Then tells them
that he's run into other students here
from other schools,
but no one seems to be in their right mind
and none of them could answer
any of his questions.
He also mentions that they are in danger
and that he saw ghosts
attacking other students earlier.
Satoshi
then says that they should split up
and look for the others and glasses
guy here agrees to send anybody
he finds to the front entrance
of the school because finding anybody
is probably a good idea
in order to increase their chances
of getting back home elsewhere.
Ayumi and Blonde Guy here
deal with the same things
that everyone else here is dealing with.
Absolute madness. I am.
He begins to lose her mind, just as Blonde
guy sees this creepy spirit.
Kid and this kid is nuts
and he charges at them ready to kill.
He suddenly pops up near Ayumi to kill her
until he gets distracted by blond hair guy
causing the spirit to disappear.
And creepy ass glasses.
Girl appears out of nowhere again.
Blond hair guy asks who the hell she is,
but glasses girl just tells him that
she's dead and that she came here
to find someone long ago.
But suddenly the most insane thing happens
because I am here recognizes glasses
girl and they follow her into the library
where I am, she tells Blond Hair Guy.
That Glasses Girl was a famous
high school blogger
who wrote all about ghosts and scary stuff
rooted in science.
Ayumi then tells Glasses Girl
that she was a huge fan
and that she even got the friendship charm
that everybody else did earlier
from her website The charm that teleported
everyone into this hell hole, blond
hair guy doesn't have time for any of this
and demands know how they get back home.
Glasses girl
then mentions that before she died,
she was researching this school,
trying to find a way back herself.
And she thinks that the spirits
of the children who died here
in 1973
is what is causing this place to exist.
Glasses girl
says that she doesn't know how to get back
but thinks that if they find
some way to make the spirits happy,
they'll let them leave.
And one way to do
this would be finding out
who the murderer really is
and to make the killer repent.
Glasses girl then says that everybody
from Ayumi's classes here
but that they are all in different
dimensions thanks to this curse.
Different dimensions but in the same place
kind of like interstellar.
Meaning that in order
to meet the rest of their friends,
they'll all have to be
within the same dimension.
Well, all right, all right, all right,
all right.
This is insane.
And even though it sounds insane,
what glasses girl said in theory
could be actually true because the world
as we know it has three dimensions
of space length, width and depth
and one dimension of time.
But according to the string theory,
the universe operates
within actually ten dimensions,
which include all possible futures and all
possible pasts, including realities
with totally different physics
than those in our known universe.
An example of this possibly can be seen
if two protons were to be smashed
together at high enough speeds, which,
if this were to happen, in theory,
their collision would have the ability
to create a tiny black hole,
which is so awesome.
And this black hole could exist
for just a fraction
of a second before disappearing.
And that very tiny
black hole would open up
a little bubble of interdimensional space
where the laws of physics would differ.
This is all still theory,
but it goes to show
that what we're experiencing
could be actually true.
And all of this
could explain the certain things,
like the weird passage of time
from where we are
and why it moves differently,
as well
as why
we can all be within the same school
but not physically
be able to see each other.
Now, with this being said in our minds,
completely blown out of the water,
I would begin looking to solve this murder
as soon as possible
because it's obvious,
judging from how crazy everybody is going,
we just can't question everybody we see.
Which means our best bet would be to work
with the most reliable pieces
of information that we have access to.
And in this case, it would be the school's
library We've seen people in here on
and off are reading
snippets of past and news articles.
So it's safe to assume
that we would be able to get the
full scoop on the murders by going through
what actually happened, by reading it.
And the library is a perfect spot
for that.
By getting our Sherlock on
and putting the pieces together at,
say, my good Watson,
that we'll be able to keep ourselves
out of harm's way for a little bit longer.
Glasses girl finishes telling these two
all of this crazy dimension shit
and she disappears without warning,
forcing the two to get moving elsewhere
in another dimension,
the kid's teacher walks down this hallway
and she reads an old newspaper
about the gruesome deaths that took place
here and reads that the children who died
here died from blood loss and asphyxiation
and had their tongues cut out as well.
Real gruesome stuff.
Suddenly she sees a light from
within a room and goes to check it out.
And she sees the most terrifying thing.
One of her students
talking with two of the murdered kids.
And this little girl says
that she's not leaving,
that she needs to be there
for the children.
The teacher tells her to snap out of it,
suddenly causing these two children
to freak out and yank the little girl
up into the air and ride out this window,
grinding her body
into mincemeat down the hallway,
smacking her into a wall, leaving nothing
but her little hair tied to show for it.
The teacher looks on in sheer horror
as she is
brutally crushed by this guy
in some other part of the school class.
This guy takes a break
finding his classmates
and he sits down to look at the pictures
from within his phone and he wonders
where his friend, this little girl is.
He begins to smile and takes a moment
to enjoy his sick fetish.
Looking at the mutilated corpses
of the school's past victims.
As he goes through his phone,
he finds one which excites him
more than all the rest.
But he just then gets a call from the dead
girl in his photo,
which makes him realize
who he's really looking at.
His beloved
classmate elsewhere, Satoshi continues
to look for a bathroom for his sister
as they run into this creepy girl,
and she leads them to what they think is
sweet most she does potty salvation,
guiding them through these doors
and out into this walkway.
But Sweet Mochida can't wait any longer.
So he tells his sister to go do her thang
near the trees in the distance,
but don't go too far.
Taking a little red dress girl
along with her, Satoshi then finds
an ID on the floor
belonging to another student
with the same piece of paper
as everyone else has.
Looks like everyone else performed
the same rituals them to get here and he
then heads inside to wait.
Okay, this is crazy.
This is probably the most insane thing
ever.
And we have yet
to address the elephant in the room
and that elephant's name is frickin
Satoshi Idiot.
Like, what are you doing?
You just frickin teleported into a literal
nightmare with ghosts out to kill you.
And you have no weapons.
You have no help. You're all alone.
And you think it's a good idea
to leave your sister alone.
I don't care
if she's with that little demon child.
That's even worse.
Leaving two kids alone in a strange place.
Are you nuts?
And to top it off, that little girl's
probably a psychotic ghost.
Like, what are you doing?
Satoshi played it so dumb, it is mind
numbing how idiotic that move is.
You already split up from Glass's guy,
and now you want to split up again
with your sister. Even temporarily.
If Satoshi had any sense,
he would have told her to just do it
in a corner with his back turn.
So at least he can make sure
that nothing happens to her.
Inside, Satoshi hears the horrifying
screams of his little sister,
but the door won't budge,
and he turns around to see little red
dress girl Sweet Mochida
bust through the door to find her brother
gone, leaving her all alone
back with Ayumi and blond guy.
They walk down the halls and they talk
about the doll that they found,
and they think that it belongs
to the killer of all of these kids.
Suddenly the doll starts talking
blond hair, guy freaks out
and trips and falls through this wall,
finding this bloody pouch.
The doll continues talking,
repenting for all of the murders
and paying it cost to those children.
Which makes me suspect that this little
doll is in fact the killer himself.
Blond haired guy gives the bloodied pouch
to Ayumi, who finds a name on it
that she thinks belonged
to one of the dead children.
Blond hair, guy
then realizes that the name belongs
to the same kid who attacked them earlier.
Just as that kid shows up and demands
that they give it back,
the kid goes into full on rage
mode and attacks
Ayumi until she quickly shoves the tongue
into the kid's face
and he suddenly stops being evil
and smiles and gets sent to heaven.
The two then realized that
they just gave back what the murderer
stole from that dead kid, meaning there's
only three spirits left to be set free
usually, and blond haired guide
then continue
to find the rest of the tongues
belonging to the other dead kids.
And with some digging they find almost
all of the tongues except one.
Something isn't right
because the last kid,
according to the news
article, was found before she died.
Ayumi suspects that they won't be able
to set the last spirit free
the same way as they did for the others.
But blond guy thinks
that if she didn't die,
then there's no need for her to be set
free.
Ayumi then mentions that
if this was the case,
that everything should have
already gone back to normal by now.
But it hasn't forcing Ayumi
to think harder about what's
really going on elsewhere.
Terrified, Mochida roams
the halls as she looks for her brother,
and she runs into good old glasses guy.
But something isn't right. About him
and she can tell.
And Glasses Guy reveals himself
to be on some serious creep
and charges at her,
and Sweet Mochida runs for her life.
She hides in sheer horror
but suddenly is found by this guy, Mr.
Stud Face, and he lure Sweet Mochida out,
telling her that he's also
looking for his little sister.
But just the glasses guy finds them.
But Mr.
Stud face moves
as good as he looks and kills glasses
sky straight into his windpipe.
Mr. Stud Face turns around to Mochida,
revealing that he too is batshit
crazy, calling Sweet Mochida.
His new sister, Mochida, runs for her life
and she is led to safety by Little Red
Dress girl.
Suddenly a massive earthquake rips through
everybody just like in the beginning.
And luckily for Ayumi and Blond Guy,
the earthquake sends them
all the way back to where it all began
their original school
back in the spare room.
Satoshi isn't as lucky,
and he continues to explore this place
instead of trying to find his sister.
What a jerk.
And he sees from this newspaper
that only one girl survived those murders
all those years ago.
And the person who survived it
looks exactly like little red dress girl.
But if she's alive, then why is she
in this hellhole with all of them?
He then finds a tape nearby
with a recent date on it and this book
that he thinks he could use
to send everybody back home.
Suddenly, Glasses Girl pops up
and tells them that they all messed up
the ritual that they did in the beginning
and she doctor strange
as his horny asked to the person he's
thinking of most in that moment.
Back in the land of the living,
these two have no clue what's going on.
Just as this portal opens up
and one of the main
murdered girls appears and mentions
that if they want to save their friends,
they'll have to do more than just return
all of the tanks to the kids.
They need to help the spirits find peace,
and she then shows them
exactly how she was brutally murdered
so they know what kind of terror
they all experienced by literally
putting Ayumi into this dead girl's shoes.
Replaying the night
that she was brutally murdered.
And Ayumi finds out
who the real killer is.
Little red dress girl.
And we find out that she ordered
the murders of all of these children.
And basically bossed around this big guy
into helping her commit these crimes.
Ayumi then wakes back up with a fright
and decides to go back into the spirit
realm to help her friends.
But blond dude was out and the dead
girl tells her to hurry because the souls
of the Heavenly Host Elementary School
have begun looking for a new host.
And soon even the good spirits
like this girl will go insane.
So with the clock ticking,
Ayumi is then teleported back
into the spirit realm to stop all of this.
This is a casebook example of
when you go to the spirit realm,
folks, you don't trust anybody,
including tiny little girls.
Little red dress girl is nuts.
And to be honest,
I wouldn't trust her with my life.
In fact, a blond hair guy here
is the only one thinking smart about this.
And is actually using his brain.
Does that make him a war still,
however? Yes.
Yes, it does.
But that's okay. He's a smart was.
And let's be honest, at most,
any of these kids are about ten years
or younger,
maybe blond hair. Guy's 13 max.
And that's the thing.
How precious is any kid relationship
you've ever had that
you must risk your life for on average
by the time you graduate and become a big
boy, you lose half of those relationships
just like that.
Which means more likely than not,
if all of these kids somehow survived,
they'll all lose touch with each other
eventually, which means they wouldn't
even be in our lives
after a certain point,
which means they might as well be dead
to begin with.
See what I did there?
I brought that logic back full circle.
If the tree falls in the forest when
no one is around, does it make a sound?
I say, No, no, it does it.
And so even if we went back
to save all of our friends right now,
we lose touch with them eventually,
which means we might as well speed up
the process of us.
Not knowing them sooner
and leave them to die right now.
Quoting Sun Tzu, The Art of War elsewhere
a given up.
Naomi lays down defeated
thanks to meatball hair
girl's death earlier and just being good
all horned dogs.
Satoshi appears near her thanks to glasses
girl and she hugs the crap out of him.
And this dude totally doesn't
feel bad about it at all, even though
he probably should have thought
of his sister instead and glasses.
Girl totally gave him the chance to.
She then tell Satoshi that maple hair
girl died and takes him to her corpse,
but he thinks something is suspicious
and that maybe the spirits
made her die because meatball
her girl wouldn't just die like that.
Which means
they can't trust anything in here.
Meanwhile, back with Sweet Mochida.
She finally escapes from Mr.
Stud face, but that's when red dress girl
turns full nutso and prepares to kill
her, forcing Sweet Mochida to yet again
run for her life, ending up in this room.
But that's when she turns around
and sees her worst nightmare.
It's Mr.
Stud Face
looking like a bloodied, possessed
anatomy mannequin
that you'd find in medical school.
He grabs most shit
a sweet face and ties her up.
He then brutally tortures her, doing
the most despicable things to Mochida.
He even scoops out her eyeball.
Ben Jerry's style
forcing her to squeal like a gutted pig.
But he doesn't stop and slowly plunges
his knife into her chest just as blond
hair guy comes in swinging, slicing Mr.
Stud faces head off, but it's too late.
Blond hair guy does try to save her,
but then this big dude comes at him
and they fight Ayumi and then arrives and
tries to get Sweet Mochida out of there.
But then she turns around and sees
blond hair guy covered in blood.
He came back to save them all,
and that was his biggest mistake.
Suddenly he gets stabbed through
the stomach, blood spilling everywhere
and he tells them with his last
breath to run.
Then suddenly a hand forces its way
through his mouth.
Nothing can stop this dude
and Ayumi and Sweet motored out.
Look, in sheer terror.
Satoshi then arrives the latest balls
thanks to Sweet Mochida screams
from earlier and saves the two,
taking them back to now.
Me this is madness and blond hair guy
kind of did move up in my book with that
superhero save there.
But here's the thing
why did he simultaneously feel the need
to become the biggest idiot in this side
of the Western Hemisphere Suite?
Meltdown was pretty much already dead
to begin with.
Let's be honest.
She was a liability from the start
and I'm amazed at that.
She made it this far,
but she was dead weight all along.
The fact is, you saw it clearly too.
Everyone was too late to save her.
And Sweet Mochida, a sweet face
was destined to get royally screwed up
since birth.
If anything, blond hair guy
should have sliced a Mr.
Stud face
and then in an act of pure mercy killing,
I'm sure plunged the dagger
into sweet mode.
She does neck,
causing her to bleed out fast.
See what I mean? Mercy killing.
Because by the time he showed up,
she was pretty much already dead.
Cut up on that tortured table.
In fact,
if he just put her out of her misery
like a true hero,
then he could have spared her
last moments of pure terror and agony.
And he could have still been alive to help
us on our journey getting out of here.
Because if you're asking me to choose
between a bad ass dude or a six year
old girl who is dumb as a fucking fish
is deadly, then it's no competition.
I'm choosing the blond a bad ass because
Sweet Mochida is certifiably useless.
And while we're on that note,
why did Blond Hair
Guy feel the need to come at the zombie
spirit?
Dude, there's weight classes
in physical sports for a reason, folks.
Just from his stature alone,
I could have told you from a distance
that that zombie spare dude is well over
six feet and is not to be messed with
because one on one, it's
highly unlikely that a high schooler
would have been able to take him on.
Blond dude risked his life
to save a six year old girl.
Come on.
They should have had most tried
to attack him from a distance.
Only to keep him at bay while they tried
to get the hell out of there.
Moral of the story, folks
don't save the kids.
Satoshi then sits outside with the sister
that he failed to save for like a loser
and the group watches and waits as sweet
mochi to sweetness ends in bitter tears
for the rest of the group.
Later on,
the gang forgets about the sister anime
style quick and recap what they know.
They talk about how little red dress girl
is the true evil around here,
and they discuss that.
The only way to make it back
home is by putting
all of the spirits to rest,
which means they got to do one thing,
get a confession from the killer.
But to do all of this,
they need their charms from earlier.
But now we like our dumb
booboo is missing hers, needlessly
complicating everything.
The group then decides to go
search the school one last time
for their teacher, and Ayumi
then has the sudden realization
that the notebook Satoshi found earlier
belongs to glasses girl.
Which, if this is true, means
that everything on her blog is a lie,
and that's when she runs into glasses.
Girl, who turns out to be batshit nuts
two and confirms what Ayumi is thinking.
Glasses Go reveals that her online blog
was a trap designed to make more people
come here and investigate
the murders that happened here.
And in doing so, sucking more people
into this curse and taking their souls.
And she claims that she did all of this
out of love for a guy that she met here
ages back.
This is the
someone she was looking for as a spirit.
All this while Ayumi then reveals
to glasses girl what she really did to her
one true love and says that this place
possessed her to kill her man.
Showing glasses girl her and her lover's
corpse causing glasses.
Girl to vomit
all black sludge and releasing her spirit
into the afterlife once and for all.
Elsewhere, Satoshi and now we find out,
thanks to this conveniently placed
book, my look at that,
that little red dress girl is trapping
all of these souls here in order
to provide the spirit of her dead mother.
With company.
And they realize that this book is The
Diary of Little Red Dress Girl's Mother.
They also find out that
this mother is the same person who died
falling down the stairs of this school.
All those years ago.
This is what caused the little red dress
girl to go crazy in the afterlife,
trapping her spirit and all of the others
who died in this place.
The two
then find a room with seals everywhere
and that's when Satoshi is suddenly hit
with a supernatural flashback.
Seeing the principal of this school
cutting out a little red dress
girl's tongue and stabbing her body.
But the flashback suddenly stops
as another earthquake rumble happens.
Breaking off this wall
and revealing a ladder,
causing the two kids to head down
further into the devil's steps
as they come across this terrifying
torture room.
They then hear footsteps coming
and they quickly hide under the table
and they see this
dude drop a meat ball girl's corpse
and he then cuts out her tongue.
The two kids look in horror
and now he loses her mind and runs after
pull hair girl's corpse.
Satoshi chases after her
but cannot find her.
Oh, my gosh. That was sickening.
Also, now he's got to cool her jets, like,
whoa, settle down, Captain Marvel.
We don't know who this this monster is.
And what is she going to do?
She's just going to run around
willy nilly.
Bad plan.
Satoshi shouldn't have even bothered
chasing after her and should have stayed
hidden because.
Have you guys played out last? I have.
This is the exact same type of shit.
I would have had the monsters
pretend to leave the area
only to sneak attack us from behind.
Nope. No thanks. Not going to do that.
If we were to go look for her,
we should look around the room
and see if there is
anything
that we could use to defend ourselves.
There's a lot of chains hanging.
Can we take those down?
There also seems to be some tools
and instruments of torture in the back
corner of the room on that table.
We should also check the closet over there
and see what's inside it.
Once we've armed ourselves
with whatever we can find,
we should cover our scent of life.
What I mean by that is these ghosts
attacking us are dead, and some of them
seem to have varying degrees
of intelligence and clarity of thought.
It makes me wonder if we were to drench
ourselves with the blood of these victims,
cover ourselves and all the tongue eager
that we can and appear to be dead.
I believe that it is possible that
we could mask our scent of being alive.
I would have preferred to test out
this theory beforehand on someone else,
but we're out of options here.
We need to maximize
our chances of survival as we wander
these haunted tunnels
looking for our friend who abandoned us
underneath this cursed school.
Thanks to the earthquake from earlier,
Ayumi sits in a bunch of rubble
and is confused as hell.
She then sees a bunch more scary shit,
just as Satoshi shows up
and tells Ayumi that everyone else
from their class, a.k.a.
all the C plot characters,
that she found are dead.
And that's
when this nice spirit shows up again
and tells these two that the Army is now
under control by the curse of this place
and that she'll need to overcome
its powers before returning back to them.
And while they wait, they head off
and finally find the corpse of a little
red dress girl laying right next
to the psycho killer head master.
And that's when the vengeful spirit
of little red dress
girl comes at them for blood
stabbing Satoshi's right hand as her good
half also shows up to the corpse party
elsewhere as Naomi continues
to fight her own demons,
this haunted place reveals to her
the most insane thing ever.
It reveals to her that it was actually her
who killed Meatball, her girl.
This place possessed her to do it.
Causing her to lose her mind.
But in all this sadness, meatball hair
girl calls Noemi from beyond the grave
to forgive her, and she finally breaks
free from the curse.
Back at this corpse party, Satoshi sets
cut to shit and tries to talk some sense
into both the good half and the bad
half of the ghost of Little Red Dress Girl
and desperately tells her
that her and her mother
were the first victims of all of this.
And we see a flashback of the headmaster
accidentally pushing her
mother down the stairs
and little red dress girl sees it all.
This is how she died
and what caused all of this.
Satoshi
then hands the good spirit, her tongue
that he found earlier and finally says
the two in one spirits free.
But suddenly the whole school
starts crumbling and this ghost girl
pops up again and tells everyone
that they need to get out of here
now, gathering
the three outside to perform
the same ritual that brought them here.
But because now we lost her charm earlier
like a dope, Satoshi
then offers his own charm for her to use,
lending her his helping hand and mentions
that he'll just use his sister's charm
that he held onto for his sister.
But turns out this kiddo lent out
one too many hands and comes up short
because when they teleport back
to their original school,
the two girls look in sheer horror
with each of them holding one of Satoshi's
bloodied arms, causing the duo to sit
at the proverbial finish line in dead
silence.
Bummer.
But what do you think about Corpse Party?
Let us know what you like
and what you didn't like about the video.
And as always.
Don't forget to leave a thumbs up
and don't forget to check out our How to
Be playlist.